salut c'est déjà d'arachide aujourd'hui
si on part aux états unis avec brut
c'est à cause de cette photo
[Musique]
le père s'appelait oscars il avait 25
ans sa fille valeria avait deux sens
deux migrants qui venait du salvador
noyé dans le rio grande et cette photo
elle a fait tour du monde et comme
beaucoup de gens c'est normal elle m'a
choqué
avec brut on a voulu comprendre la
réalité derrière cette photo alors on
est parti à la frontière des états unis
et du mexique
là où oscar et valeria ont vécu leurs
derniers jours dans le camp de migrants
de matamoros à seulement 500 mètres de
la frontière américaine d'émigrants
d'amérique centrale désespéré et par
milieu des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants
les premières victimes d'un trump qui
rêvent de fermer les frontières comme
d'habitude toujours aussi trash est dans
le camp de matamoros au mexique
il n'y a pas de haine j'ai plus de mille
réfugiés dont 300 enfants vivent sans
l'eau potable et dorment dans des tentes
olam est un bon gars
[Musique]
ces familles tiennent le coup c'est
grâce à l'aide de bénévoles américain
qui chaque jour passent la frontière
pour leur apporter à manger à boire
[Musique]
pour sa part qu'elle allait appliquer
ces gamins se prononçant pas
[Musique]
donc on
hautmont
iman al aussi nécessairement les cuisses
avec msn
une protection
[Musique]
m
ce camp de réfugiés est un parfait
résumé de la politique migratoire de
donald trump tous les moyens sont bons
pour décourager ceux qui veulent rentrer
aux états unis y compris emprisonner des
enfants de migrants
l'an dernier plus de 2300 enfanté
séparés de leur famille et placés dans
des centres de détention aux us des
centres de détention qui sont forcément
interdit aux journalistes
alors pour en parler nous avons
rencontré une avocate en colère qui elle
a pu y rentrer
[Musique]
malgré un after a faim et aux sms car
l'offre est variée et nice parce qu'elle
sait aussi
[Musique]
des 16 mai à vendeville
il n'y a pas que des anti drogue dans
cette ville américaine à seulement 5
minutes de la frontière mexicaine
le président à ses fans et devinez quoi
ils nous ont donné rendez vous au stand
de tir de la ville
[Musique]
dans un entrepôt joue sa réélection et
il est déjà en campagne son discours
forcément n'a absolument pas changé
comme il ya quatre ans ils tablent sur
les migrants les parents et les enfants
il serait bête d'arrêter ça lui a déjà
bien réussi
[Applaudissements]
give them to report à la ruine
vous avez compris maintenant train pas
une seule obsession l'immigration et son
rêve tient toujours
c'est de construire un mur de 3000 km
qui séparaient les états unis du mexique
mais avec brut on a voulu finir ce
reportage avec des citoyens américains
qui rêve d'autre chose
des citoyens qui n'oublie pas que eux
aussi leurs ancêtres viennent d'ailleurs
un peu comme chez nous d'ailleurs et je
suis le premier concerné
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
on
[Musique]